[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est vous marie-luciet
bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes référente plaidoyer droit et
santé sexuelle et reproductive chez
Médecin du Monde ce 28 septembre c'est
la journée mondiale du droit à
l'avortement un droit auquel non pas
accès toutes les femmes dans le monde
aujourd'hui et pourtant une femme sur
trois corrigez-moi si je me trompe il y
aura recours une fois dans sa vie au
moins légalement ou dans la
clandestinité pourquoi est-ce que
l'accès à l'IVG est une question de
santé publique
c'est une question de santé publique en
effet parce qu'aujourd'hui 40 000 femmes
meurent chaque année des suites d'un
avortement qui s'est déroulées dans des
mauvaises conditions de santé pourquoi
dans des mauvaises conditions de santé
parce qu'il s'est déroulé dans un pays
où il est illégal quand il est légal il
se passe dans des bonnes conditions de
santé quand il est illégal les femmes se
mettent en danger et c'est pour ça que
c'est vraiment un soin de santé
essentiel qualifié d'ailleurs comme tel
par l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
pourquoi est-ce qu'une femme avorte
alors c'est vrai que nous on est on est
une association de santé on est des
soignants les raisons intimes et
personnelles qui font que les femmes des
couples et des hommes trans avortent ça
ça ne nous appartient pas en revanche
pourquoi y a-t-il des grossesses non
planifiées là il y a des causes beaucoup
plus structurelles les principales
causes c'est le manque
universel pour le coup ça vaut dans tous
les pays d'accès à l'éducation complète
à la sexualité une éducation qui fait
que les personnes notamment les jeunes
connaissent leur corps connaissent la
sexualité
apprennent à ne pas avoir de pratique à
risque connaissent la reproduction ça
c'est un élément clé et évidemment
l'accès à l'information et l'accès aux
contraception ça se trouve vraiment deux
causes qui font qu'il y a une grossesse
sur deux dans le monde aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas planifié plus de 40% des
femmes en âge de concevoir vivre
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans des états
aux lois restrictives dans quel sens va
cette tendance globalement sur ces
dernières années alors c'est un panorama
assez contrasté c'est à dire que depuis
environ 30 40 ans il y a plus de 60
États qui ont quand même assoupli leur
législation il y en a que 4 qui ont eu
des vrais recul au niveau du droit donc
il y a plus de gains sur une courbe
historique mais avec quand même des
régressions extrêmement symboliques et
symptomatique aussi que ces droits ne
sont jamais vraiment acquis à ce titre
qu'est-ce que le cas américain avec la
décision il y a quelques mois de la Cour
suprême de casser l'arrêt versus wild
représente alors déjà ça représente plus
de 20 millions de femmes qui n'ont pas
accès à l'avortement de femmes
américaines qui n'ont pas accès à
l'avortement aujourd'hui donc ça c'est
quand même le premier point et après
c'est vrai que les États-Unis évidemment
quand on a une influence internationale
très importante donc ça crée une onde de
choc ça ça résonne et beaucoup de pays
ça ouvre la voie à beaucoup d'autres
pays pour des mesures restrictives et
pour des des recul dans leur législation
ce que vous constatez j'imagine dans
votre travail c'est que l'interdiction
de l'IVG ou la durcification de l'accès
à l'IVG n'empêche pas les femmes qui
veulent qui doivent avorter d'y avoir
recours en revanche c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure la clandestinité
là à des conséquences terribles oui tout
à fait il y a vraiment deux cas de
figure c'est à dire que
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est qu'une
femme une femme une personne qui
souhaite avorter le fera il y a de
solution soit elle le fait dans des
conditions de santé satisfaisante et ne
se met pas en danger soit elle se met en
danger la grosse différence aussi et
c'est en ça que ce sont également des
lois de classe si elle a les moyens
d'apporter elle pourra toujours prendre
un avion prendre un train trouver un
praticien privé pour avorter des bonnes
conditions si elle n'a pas les moyens là
pour le coup il y a vraiment une mise en
danger donc les lois ne vont jamais
empêcher les personnes de prendre des
décisions aussi fondamentales sur leur
vie c'est pas la loi qui empêche les
avortements ce qui va vraiment empêcher
qu'il y ait des grossesses non désirées
c'est ce que je disais l'éducation à la
sexualité les contraceptifs c'est pas la
loi ça a un effet contre-productif et
extrêmement dangereux pour les femmes
c'est ça qui est vraiment inacceptable
c'est que c'est 40 000 décès dont je
parle et c'est sans compter 7 millions
de femmes hospitalisées c'est
inacceptable pour des pour des soignants
et pour une société et votre propos bien
sûr n'est pas j'imagine d'inciter qui
que ce soit à avorter chacun est libre
de son choix mais de dire que l'égaliser
la pratique permettrait de sauver voilà
au moins 40 000 vues par an tout à fait
notre propos est de dire que les
décisions des individus leur choix leurs
appartiennent
[Musique]
en Hongrie avec des mesures très
restrictives en Roumanie ou en Italie là
avec l'élection récente mais mais mais
déjà avant ça en Italie par exemple plus
de 70% des médecins sont objectoires de
conscience donc refuse le soin
d'avancement ça veut dire que ce n'est
pas parce que l'IVG n'est interdit
formellement que dans une vingtaine de
pays dans le monde ce qui est quand même
énorme qu'il est qu'il est respecté dans
les faits dans les pays dans lequel il
est censé être être légal oui tout à
fait il y a vraiment deux de choses
importantes c'est le la loi sécuriser la
loi la protéger la défendre la maintenir
et l'accès réel et ça l'accès réel il
dépend de plein d'autres facteurs la
disponibilité de l'accès à l'information
du nombre de soignants évidemment dans
les différents territoires qui
pratiquent les avortements des
sages-femmes des gynécos donc cet accès
là il est pas toujours corrélé à la loi
et en France par exemple c'est aussi un
des éléments très important
on va revenir sur la France dans un
instant mais ce que vous constatez ça
peut paraître peut-être paradoxal mais
c'est que dans la les dans les pays où
la législation va plutôt dans le sens de
de faciliter l'accès à l'IVG et bien on
voit le nombre de divgés pour le coup
qui diminue oui ça c'est un constat
qu'on met d'ailleurs on l'a aussi fait
en France au moment de la loi veille
c'est-à-dire que
souvent quand un pays
légalise l'avortement il l'accompagne
d'une politique beaucoup plus globale
sur
la place des femmes aussi dans la
société sur l'éducation la sexualité sur
l'accès aux contraceptif ça n'arrive
jamais seul ça va de pair avec tout ça
d'ensemble de mesures et cet ensemble de
mesures font que le nombre de grossesses
qui ne sont pas planifiés de fait va
diminuer ce qui veut dire que très
souvent en valeur vraiment totale avant
une loi pour l'avortement et après il y
a une baisse alors évidemment ce nombre
d'avortement là devient de cette
sécurisé mais surtout il y a une se
passe vraiment du volume d'avortement
alors est-ce que en France aujourd'hui
ou l'accès à l'IVG bien sûr et depuis la
loi veille tout à fait favorisée est-ce
que c'est un droit qui est acquis alors
à qui effectivement on est aujourd'hui
on est de plus en plus frileux à penser
que des droits sont acquis on sait à
quel point il faut toujours rester
mobilisé
donc ça fait plus ça fait un peu plus de
40 ans que la loi est passée en France
du fait des très fortes mobilisations
des mouvements féministes qui ont
ensuite
œuvré pour des évolutions de ce cadre
pour que ce soit gratuit avec des délais
prolongés etc donc c'est encore même en
constante évolution au niveau du cadre
légal après au niveau de l'accès
effectivement on remarque qu'il y a des
inégalités il y a des inégalités
territoriales déjà avorté dans une
grande ville ou avorter dans un désert
médical évidemment c'est pas la même
chose il y a des endroits en France où
les femmes doivent faire des kilomètres
et des kilomètres pour pouvoir avorter
ça c'est des barrières très fortes et
c'est aussi il y a aussi des barrières
sociales à l'accès c'est à dire que
quand on ne parle pas la langue qu'on ne
sont beaucoup les femmes qu'on rencontre
un médecin du monde qu'on ne qu'on ne
connaît pas bien le système de santé
qu'on a un petit peu perdu dans ce
système ça crée beaucoup de barrières
qui font que beaucoup de ces femmes
finalement ont une grande difficulté à
avorter correctement dans les délais qui
sont qui sont légaux et puis il y a
cette réflexion depuis quelques mois
poussé par une partie de la classe
politique française qui voudrait que ce
droit soit inscrit dans la Constitution
qu'est-ce que ça change
je pense que tout ce qui peut être mis
en place pour sécuriser ce droit pour
vraiment le protéger quand il est en
place est important donc l'installer
dans la Constitution c'est c'est
vraiment une étape qui peut être forte
en France parce qu'on ne sait pas de
quoi l'avenir est fait au niveau des
forces politiques mais aussi sur le
signal que ça peut envoyer à
l'international ça le signal qui a été
envoyé par par la fin de la loi
nationale aux États-Unis a été très fort
ça crée une onde de choc si on pouvait
créer une onde de chocs contraire qui
rappelle qu'avant tout c'est un soin ces
marqueurs bien sûr d'égalité de liberté
d'émancipation mais c'est aussi un soin
pour le coup ça peut aussi permettre à à
d'autres pays éventuellement de et aux
femmes aussi de rester mobilisés et de
maintenir ce combat
un droit qui va avec d'autres droits
humains et droits des femmes en
l'occurrence merci beaucoup